am gärtnerplatz in münchen will die
polizei am samstagmorgen um 1 und 23 1
man eine ausweiskontrolle unterziehen
bereits im vorfeld haben sieben
polizisten bei mehreren menschen
kontrollen durchgeführt
der mann wehrt sich offenbar gegen die
kontrolle es kommt zum gerangel mit zwei
beamten dient zu einem streifenwagen
bringen wollen bekannte des mannes
versuchen die kontrolle zu verhindern
dabei werden auch schlagstöcke
eingesetzt ein beamter schlägt mehrfach
mit seinem schlagstock zu und trifft
dabei einen anderen mann ins gesicht
daraufhin folgt eine heftige
auseinandersetzung nach kurzer zeit
trifft verstärkung der polizei ein unter
anderem eine einsatzhundertschaft erst
dann kann die situation unter kontrolle
gebracht werden
später kommt es zur festnahme von zwei
personen in einer seitenstraße es
handelt sich um männer die den
kontrollierten befreien wollten
der mann der vom schlagstock getroffen
wurde erlitt eine blutende wunde an der
lippe und musste von einem
rettungssanitäter versorgt werden die
polizei war mit mehr als 20
streifenwagen im einsatz
am gärtnerplatz kam es in der
vergangenheit immer wieder zu
polizeieinsätzen partygänger halten die
mindestabstände nicht ein und machen
lärm
erst am mittwoch hat der münchner
stadtrat auf antrag der csu fraktion ein
neues alkoholverbot in münchen
beschlossen nach dem hin und her der
letzten tage aber nicht mehr stadtweit
sondern nur für hotspots an denen sich
viele menschen draußen treffen
[Musik]
das war natürlich eine sehr heftige
auseinandersetzung ich war in den
vergangenen wochen häufiger gärtnerplatz
den kommt es immer wieder zu hohe
störungen und lärmbelästigung und dann
ist situation komplett eskaliert um 1
uhr 23 dazu die polizei eine gruppe von
schwarzen kontrollieren polizeiangaben
waren das rund 25 bis 30 leute die haben
sich gegen mitternacht und hat ihr volk
gemischt und hat laute musik gehört und
daraufhin sind vier beamte auf die
gruppe zugegangen wollte es war auch
eine ausweiskontrolle durchführen
dagegen hat sich dann derjenige gewährt
und wollte seine personalien nicht
herausgeben dann wollte man ihn zum
streifenwagen führen und da sieht man
das ja wie ich auf diesen videos dann
freunde oder bekannte greifen dann die
polizisten an wollten das unterbinden
wollten das errichten kann und dabei
wurde auch mehrfach der schlagstock
eingesetzt
nach 30 sekunden kam dann auch mehr
unterstützung das und dabei der ganze
wurde der ganze gärtnerplatz geräumt
dann kann auch die bereitschaftspolizei
wir haben die bilder gesehen sieht
heftig aus hat sich denn die polizei zu
den festnahmen am gärtnerplatz jetzt
mittlerweile schon im detail geäußert
im detail noch nicht die polizei hat mir
aber kurz vor 12 uhr bestätigt dass
jetzt aus neutralitätsgründen das
bayerische landeskriminalamt das
sachgebiet für interne ermittlungen
diesem fall jetzt übernommen hat denn
die beamten prüfen jetzt den
schlagstockeinsatz es beamten der ja
da den mann der da wo wir es jetzt sehen
können noch mal im bild das müsste es
gleich zu sehen sein werden aus wurde
und jetzt den mann mit dem hut dann im
gesicht trifft und weil es ist
eigentlich tabu polizisten schlagen
nicht in richtung des kopfes da können
scherzte wenn es sogar tödliche
verletzungen zugefügt werden
deswegen zog das landeskriminalamt ob
dieser einsatz angemessen war
mein eindruck war allerdings das ist
hier ein gerangel gab die situation war
komplett außer kontrolle dass der
polizist nur ausholen wollte um die
menge in schach zu halten und auf
abstand zu halten und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass er nicht vor hatte
den mann gezielt ins gesicht zu schlagen
weil das machen polizisten in der regel
nicht mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren